c'est qui qui a dit que j'étais un
abruti qui se prend pour dieu x
attention je vous donnais des indices
pizza et donc à volonter easy star ouais
lorsqu'il a dit publie un nouveau livre
voilà et il a dit hanouna est un abruti
je comprends pas ils doivent bien me
connaître il a et il a raconté en fait
l'histoire de la nouvelle star avec
gilles alors voilà deux sets ce
malheureux épisode on voulait rigole
avec lui et qui vous incarnez l'apa il
n'a pas rigolé adultes il n'a pas aimé
voilà votre petite blague des pizzas et
depuis paraît que joey starr
malheureusement ne mange plus de pizzas
voilà donc le week end une position
parce que dans son livre j'en ai un
petit bout la wii
il espère que l'on vous a remercié de
nouvelle star oui or vous aviez annoncé
avant votre départ que si la le fola
paul marché la pop art dont vous
arrêteriez l'émission donc c'est pas
vrai pour le coup alors il m'a dit va
interviewer nabila mec nous fait pas
chier côté voilà donc il est des nervis
voilà il faut plus y prend d expression
d idy se prend pour dieu le père on voit
qu'il a vieilli joey starr
jouer chloé mon chéri moi j'ai rien
contre toi et tu sais maintenant je
t'appelle joey puisque pour moi il n'y a
plus que deux jours et tu n'as plus rien
d'une star
donc voilà donc c'est juste de jouer
voilà